so we've gotten a lot of feedback now
from a couple of different users next we
need to figure out if the prototype did
well or poorly remember we don't need to
have users love our app design as a
whole at this point we are working with
a low fidelity prototype so our goal is
simply to get a sense of whether the
story of the app makes sense could users
go through and actually make sense of
the app could they do the things we
wanted them to when considering whether
the prototype got us the information we
needed we need to look at whether we
have answers to all the critical
questions around our app story questions
about how to fix flaws in our app after
we have found them may also become
critical the only way to find this out
is to look at the feedback we got from
our users here I have the notes I took
from the conversation with Hugh and
poornima about this and it looks like we
got pretty solid feedback on that both
of them jump straight to the floating
action button and we're certain that it
did the right thing we can call that
part of our app a success